[Musique]
le vernissage de l'exposition histoire
des hommes et des espèces à la réunion
s'est déroulée ce 6 juillet à mascara
jardin botanique de la réunion chef de
file de la préservation de la
biodiversité du département a soutenu ce
projet porté par la v e 2e l'association
pour la valorisation de l'entré deux
mondes
on voulait à travers cette exposition
effectivement rappelé à ce qu'était la
réunion il ya 300 ans en arrière ce
qu'est la réunion aujourd'hui et surtout
passer un message d'alerté pour
l'ensemble des acteurs du département et
notamment la population pour dire
effectivement beaucoup ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de mal qui étaient causés mais
aujourd'hui on encore de la chance
d'avoir encore des des reliquats des dés
de notre végétation d'origine
on en croit des espèces indigènes et
endémiques précieuse 1 qui n'existe qu'à
la réunion qu'il faut absolument
sauvegarder
donc le message qu'on passe aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on se mobilise douce et
notamment la population un conte hier
tous dans le même sens pour réussir
affections qu'effectivement à combattre
ces espèces invasion et à sauvegarder
nos espèces comment qui guide les
précieuses qui nous restent aussi bien
pour nous que pour les nouvelles
générations qui vont arriver le
département nous a demandé
2 dirt une relecture critique en fait et
puis d'abord tu es aussi bas des
éléments quand j'en avais d'apporter de
l'iconographie donc apporter enfin que
les informations qu'ils soient dans
cette exposition soit à la fois
vulgariser mai soit juste qu'on véhicule
pas des choses fausses voilà qu'elle
soit le plus précise possible pour
apporter une réelle plus value à cette
exposition
le coût de ce projet de grande envergure
financée par les fonds européens feader
s'élève à près de 280 mille euros dont
75 mille euros cofinancée par la
collectivité départementale alors le
département travaille déjà depuis
plusieurs années avec la veille deuxième
qui est notre opérateur historique sur
la partie valorisation et préservation
des espaces ils nous ont proposé donc
ans devenu 2019
une exposition à but pédagogique assure
l'histoire de l'homme et des espèces et
nous avons tout de suite dit oui parce
qu'il s'agit exactement du type d'action
qui nous permet de sensibiliser au mieux
tout type de public et en priorité les
jeunes et une exposition itinérante qui
sera présenté dans une vingtaine de
sites ainsi que plusieurs établissements
scolaires
[Musique]